the demo samuel contract situation
yeah it seems quiet
and i don't know if that's a good thing
or a bad thing
i think it's a good thing i think debo
i mean again outside looking in uh the
thing i've said from the start where i
just i always thought this would be
resolved as one
he's the best player on their football
team he's the number one weapon on their
team and shanahan with all his you know
runs and reverses and sweeps and play
action passes who's better at doing that
than debo samuel so from that standpoint
i went man san francisco ain't gonna let
him go and then the other thing i said
from the start with florio a lot was
shanahan has the utmost confidence and
his ability to communicate with players
you know he he sean mcvay some of these
young coaches you know they can tote ta
or what do i want to say toe the the
fine line a little bit of hey we're
friends but i'm your coach and i might
cuss you out a little bit here and there
and tell you to be better at this and i
just always thought shanahan would kind
of work his way through to debo and
i don't think it'll i think it's a
matter of time before we hear something
done long term